Transcriptor: Julio Delgadillo
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Muchas gracias...
El más grave error de la humanidad
Dejas de soñar, de imaginar, de crear
dejas de hacer la diferencia en el mundo.
Hola, yo soy Sofía Molina,
tengo 10 años de edad
y me consideran una activadora
para la construcción de un futuro
cierto y feliz a través de la niñez.
Y tengo unas preguntas para ti:
¿Recuerdas cuando, sin dudarlo,
hacías amistades fácilmente?
¿Cuando tu familia y amigos eran
los héroes, los astronautas,
los exploradores y mucho más?
¿cuando te divertías sin límites?
¿cuando compartías tus cosas con gusto?
... y eras muy feliz.
y seguro también recordarás
que a los niños nos limitan.
Lo que reduce nuestra capacidad como
adultos, nos dicen que nada hagamos
supuestamente para protegernos, que para
que no nos lastimemos; justo ahí es cuando
nos meten ese miedo a caer, a perder, a
no poder y es cuando lo dejamos sabiendo
que desde un principio,
teníamos toda la seguridad del mundo.
Y sí, quizá nos faltaba experiencia, pero
¿qué acaso no se trata de eso?
de aprender, de vivir. Lo peor: ahora
dicen niñas y niños, ellas y ellos que
según para darnos mayores oportunidades.
Pero, ¿qué no todos somos chiquitos y
merecemos el mismo trato?
¿Por qué nos dividen?
En fin, lo dejo aquí para que lo
reflexiones. Cuando somos niños, todo es
posible, somos súper
imaginativos, creativos, amistosos,
confiables, podemos hacer amistades a
donde vayamos, tenemos la capacidad de
de aprender y entender todas esas cosas
que nos transmiten.
Nos llama la atención que cuando hay
un día de lluvia digan que es mal tiempo
si la lluvia es maravillosa, alimenta las
plantas, ríos, mares, lagunas y mucho más.
Y además, ¿a quién no le gusta mojarse y
saltar en los charcos de agua?
Para nosotros un día lluvioso es
simplemente un excelente día
cuando nacemos, venimos al mundo con
las mismas oportunidades, los impedimentos
han crecido contigo, pueden irse
fortaleciendo y provocar barreras y miedos
pero no tiene que ser así. ¿Te imaginarías
llegar a tu trabajo actuando como niño?
Saludando a todos sonriendo, compartiendo
historias divertidísimas y disfrutando
del momento. ¿Qué pensarían de ti?
¿qué te dirían? ¿Pensarían que eres feliz
o que se te zafó un tornillo? Pero lo
importante es lo que tú pensarías
de ti mismo. ¿Te atreverías a hacerlo?
Propongo una pequeña dinámica:
Sonríe a la persona de tu alrededor,
salúdalos.
Dales un pequeño abrazo.
¿Cómo se sintieron? ¿Se sintieron bien?
¿Lo disfrutaron?
Para continuar, quisiera platicarles
un poquito sobre lo que estoy haciendo.
Actualmente, soy reconocida por
diferentes organismos, tanto por
Naciones Unidas como por diferentes
premios como lo son TUI, Héroes de
la sostenibilidad e innovación turística
con el primer lugar en la categoría Héroes
del futuro, compitiendo contra una tesis
de maestría y una generación de diversidad
completa, la verdad fue complicado pero lo
logramos; y otro fue Latinoamérica verde
como su nombre lo dice, a nivel
Latinoamérica participando
con alrededor de 3700 concursantes gané
el tercer lugar en la categoría Bosques y
Flora donde mi jurado fue perteneciente a
National Geographic, WWF,
el Banco Interamericano de Desarrollo,
los académicos e investigadores.
Actualmente tenemos
a COCOCU, la abeja y el Chiviscoyo
tenemos un club organizado por la
fundación de Naciones Unidas donde todas
las niñas pueden participar. El COCOCU
con más alcance es el jaguar,
con alrededor de 11 000 hectáreas sumadas
voluntariamente que puedes ir a conocer
Hemos platicado con alrededor de 1,500
niños, con tan buen alcance que algunos se
convirtieron en embajadores de COCOCU
y se encargan de concienciar a la gente
sobre el cuidado e importancia
del desarrollo sostenible.
Ahora, quiero hacer un trato contigo,
apoya a las ideas y los sueños de los
niños, no les hagas pensar que son vacías,
que son pasajeras para que esos niños no
se enfermen de un grave mal que es tan
difícil de combatir llamado desesperanza.
Ayúdame a que se conviertan en adultos
muy felices conviviendo con niños aún más,
todos podemos hacer un gran cambio.
Nosotros los niños lo que queremos es que
nos guien, que nos impulsen, que crean que
desde la niñez activamente podemos forjar
nuestro futuro hoy. No sabemos esperar
a 2030 o 2050 para que llegue un cambio.
Debemos de comenzarlo hoy. Piensa
en el futuro de tu hijo, tu sobrino, nieto
amiguito... ellos dirán: "Gracias mamá,
papá, abuelos, amigos, lo construimos
muy bien". Cree en ti porque con pequeñas
acciones, puedes lograr un gran cambio.
No necesitas ser extraordinario para
cambiar el universo, por que naces
con el don de soñar, de imaginar y de
crear un mundo mejor en todo sentido.
Entonces, en mi experiencia,
el más grave error de la humanidad es:
Dejar de ser niños, vuelve a ser niño.
¡Hasta siempre!